[Applause]
your
majesties prime minister dear
Alexandre president of the European
Council president of the Senate dear
colleagues ladies and
gentlemen tonight we celebrate the
beginning of a new year and the
beginning of the Belgian
presidency but as we celebrate Europe
together
tonight I want to pay tribute to a great
European to whom we bit Farwell this
morning the late commission president
jacqu
delore
it was right here in the P de
bzar that he decided to give his legacy
speech at the very end of his presidency
of the European
commission it was 30 years ago a dark
winter night just like
tonight in the presence of the Future
King
Philip and the Bazar tributed him with a
neverend ing Standing
Ovation he loved Brussels and Brussels
loved him
back we all owe so much to jacqu
delore he turned an economic Community
into a union of people and
Nations there's a quote by the LA that
has accompanied me since the very first
day of my
mandate
he said it at the beginning of the
1990s the fall of the Iron Curtain had
created great geopolitical turmoil but
also great hopes that all of Europe
could finally unite in peace and
democracy Jac Tor was the first to
understand and I quote we should not
only enlarge the community we should
unify
Europe end of
quote and for this Europe had to
ReDiscover its Soul we had to go back to
our roots to the founding values of our
Union so that we could craft a Way
Forward ladies and
gentlemen many have and will in the next
weeks and days speak of the Law's
remarkable very often historic
achievements they will no doubt praise
and rightly so the countless Landmark
policies he
fathered from the Euro to the single
Market from shenen to
erasmos they will no doubt applaud and
rightly so his decisive
leadership in making our Union even
fairer stronger and more
integrated they will no doubt
celebrate and rightly so the founding
architect of the modern European union
and I will join them as much and as many
times as I can in
both honoring his his extraordinary
Legacy and expressing our deepest
gratitude but tonight I also want to
look
ahead tonight I want not only to speak
about all that Jac delore has done for
us but on how we can take inspiration
from
him Jac theor presided the Commission in
a period marked by
tremendous geopolitical
challenges a horrific war on our
continent a structural reshuffle of the
international World
Order and the profound European
aspirations of millions at our
borders as we face today many of the
same
challenges let us take inspiration from
what he believed
in Jack the law believed in peace he
knew that an occupation could never
result in a just and Lasting
peace he had inherited from his father a
Gravely and permanently wounded World
War I
veteran the unshakable
conviction that mutual respect
and constructive dialogue must Prevail
between
nations jacqu delor believed in
solidarity he understood before anyone
else the absolute
necessity of enlarging our Union to the
east in the immediate aftermath of the
fall of the Berlin
Wall he understood before anyone else
the absolute necessity of ensuring
cohesion equity and just wealth
distribution among European
peoples and jacqu delore believed in
Europe he trusted our democratic values
and
traditions he trusted our way of life
our attachment to
fairness and our commitment to Freedom
to be the unique source of positive
influence in the
world and he trusted that we are never
as powerful as when we act all together
as Europeans United behind a common
purpose ladies and
gentlemen the
challenges that the law faced were
unique and yet not so distant
from those we face
today in this Belgian
presidency we will also have to focus on
restoring our economic
competitiveness reforming our Union and
unifying our
continent so once again we should take
inspiration from ja theore whatever the
difficulties we
Face however severe they might
appear we should always remember his
advice to Future
Generations ladies and
gentlemen at the start of this Belgian
presidency let us all be
inspired by his energy and his faith in
Europe and let me wish you all a great
evening here at bzar thank you and Long
Live Europe thank
you
thank you